اخبار سوريا وتركيا بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم نحو 30 الف قتيل حصيله
ضحايا الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا قافله
مساعدات امميه جديده تدخل المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا والامم المتحده
تقر بالفشل في ايصال المساعدات وتؤكد على
ضروره معالجته باسرع وقت وتقول ان اكثر من
خمسه ملايين سوري باتوا بلا ماوى المبعوث
الاوروبي الى سوريا يدعو دمشق الى عدم
تسييس ملف المساعدات الانسانيه ويرفض
اتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي بالتقصير في تقديم
ما يكفي من المساعدات للسوريين قائلا ان
الاتحاد ظل يقدم مساعدات للسوريين منذ
اكثر من عشر سنوات وهو يفعل المزيد خلال
ازمه الزلزال حسب قوله وفي تركيا استمرار
العثور على ناجين من تحت الانقاض نائب
الرئيس التركي يؤكد اتخاذ اجراءات لمواجهه
احتمال انتشار الاوبئه والسلطات تعتقل
عشرات المقاولين بسبب مخالفات في البناء
ادت الى انهيارات
الى اللقاء